minute and a half
Tamil Nadu vizag
particular from Bangalore
Bangladesh
Gemma Kashmir
great morat
people from India all the way from north
to south and east to west
and across the border into Bangladesh
that's great
and I'm going to go ahead and
get the session started
let me
bring up the presentation and then I
will start the live stream for our
audience
on LinkedIn
sure that I'm doing that correctly
thank you
for a moment
nope
one moment might be right back as Zoom
causes me a little bit of heartburn here
I'll be right back
okay
we have to zoom
knocks me off but I will get this uh
stream started
and we are now live on LinkedIn as well
as I Believe YouTube and zoom
for the presentation so
apologize for that glitch and I
apologize for my cough I
you have a small head cold but
um we are here to talk about how to
become a creator of products that
Delight users UI ux
Advanced certification program
from
iiit Bangalore
um
we'll be talking a little bit about UI
and ux I'll be asking you some questions
in the audience through a poll device on
Zoom if you're watching on LinkedIn or
YouTube you can answer in our comments
with a B C or D but if you're on Zoom
you'll be able to answer the poll
directly
um and we'll talk about what this
program offers how it gets you job ready
then I'll cover some enrollment steps
and a bonus offer that will be sharing
with you at the end of the
presentation and then we'll go into a q
a with Dr Preeti and arnab and to get
ready for that please put your questions
in the Q a function in Zoom or into the
chatter comment box of your streaming
service then we'll be able to take this
that time
so uh
pretty I will let you introduce yourself
because you know more about you than I
do
thanks very much Stuart and a very good
evening to everyone thank you for
joining us today uh my name is I'm an
assistant professor at uh triple it
Bangalore in the ITN Society domain and
also a faculty member and the MSC
Digital Society program I teach core
courses in
a human computer interaction qualitative
research methods and an elective course
in advanced human computer interaction I
hold a PhD in communication studies from
the University of Texas at Austin uh
post my PhD I worked as a research
assistant with Xerox Research Center
India and subsequently moved to Academia
at triple it Bangalore where I currently
am
um my research interests are mainly uh
in the domain of human computer
interaction and I research and publish
in this particular domain and especially
interested in matters related to gender
infrastructure how they are designed
implemented what constraints influence
the way people interact and access
resources how are they designed how are
they implemented
um and I'm interested both in use as
well as scenarios of non-use
because when it comes to technology uh
just studying use is not necessarily the
most fruitful Endeavor but uh remaining
attentive to instances of non-use can
often yield
um very interesting insights
so um I have a range of interests uh
that coil is around technology use
access design implementation
use and non-news and I'd be happy to
answer questions that you may have as we
proceed through this slide deck
thank you your your comments about
non-user reminds me of the anecdote
that's the been popular recently about
study of planes returning from combat in
World War II when they looked at the
patterns of the bullet holes in the
planes
the first thought was
let's
put armor where all the bullet holes are
and then somebody said no
those are the places where the plane can
get shot and not be destroyed you have
to put armor in there everywhere else to
protect those because if apparently if
it gets shot there it will never come
back so looking at non-use is kind of
like looking at really bullet take us
through uh
UI ux as a field why it's important and
what are the the kinds of roles people
can play in it
certainly thanks thanks for the design
in the context of UI and ux and what I
often tell my students is that
um this kind of design what you
encounter in an interface is often an
organization's articulation of not only
the services and the products that they
are able to offer but also how they go
about uh doing this because that is
often the very first
interaction that a customer would have
with your organization with the kind of
products you're offering with the kind
of service offerings that you are able
to put out into the world
and therefore both user interface and
the design of user experiences are very
crucial to the way the customer
experiences your organization and
therefore the success of the products
the services and the systems that they
would be offering
so the more cleaner uh and the more
friction free your customers experience
um with this front-facing customer
interface that there is there
um
um it it helps your users it helps
visitors to your organization understand
information and control the systems in a
more simpler and natural manner
um a rule of thumb that is often spoken
about in design is you don't really need
to reinvent the wheel you need to find
things that mimic what people are
already used to what people are familiar
with
um try and be as close as you can to how
the real world functions and look for
ways to translate that
um
to the kind of interfaces that you're
building because
um people look for continuity right and
an excellent user experience is
something that does not really require
people to pause and understand and try
to discover information in a new way
they would prefer doing things that come
naturally to them and come intuitively
to them and a lot of uh ux ux design ux
research roles are really geared towards
understanding how best can we optimize
the systems that we are building to
support users in executing these tasks
so an excellent user experience as a
slide tells you will contribute towards
making interactions with the kind of
products that you're building for your
organization the kind of services that
you're offering more intuitive more
pleasing and it will also result in
higher retention rates of your customer
lower attrition uh more stickiness you'd
have more people coming back to you over
and over again
um and the kind of digital world that we
inhabit today the importance of
interface-based interactions cannot be
over emphasized enough
um and therefore there's certainly
shapes how we interact with the world
how we perceive it and what we're
willing to spend time on and how much
time do we want to spend on these things
next slide
so I'm going to spend a little time
briefly talking about
um what you can expect to do as a UI or
a
ux designer in research so we conduct a
lot of primary research we are
um engaged in um what we call as field
work which essentially means that um
you're interacting with a lot of your
users or you're interacting with people
who may be potential users or you may be
interacting with people who are not your
users trying to understand how best you
could convert them and what what are the
pain points that they have that makes
them
um not be a part of your customer base
um and therefore in if if this is if
this is a kind of mandate that you have
then you can think of um what a UI or a
ux designer does is that
um they had the rain at their disposal a
vast range of students that they used to
conduct research and
um researchers many components to it so
starting right from identifying who your
target user groups may be
um going out and speaking to them in the
form of con formal interviews informal
conversations uh conducting field
observations
um did you use
um and this could take the form of um
you know formalized user tests just
shadowing your users trying to
understand how they go about
um everyday activities and how is it
that your product or your service fits
within the Ambit
um of their routines
um you then take these inside
it's that you've gathered from the field
you come back
um to your design team and
um you idiot and you
you try and analyze your data to find
out how we could build customized
experiences for your users because
you've conducted surveys you've
conducted in their interviews you've
conducted field observation so how are
you what are you going to be using this
data for and how do you analyze this
data and what do you convert it into
so the kind of assets that we create
from uh the data from the primary data
collection that we do generally takes
the form of uh things such as personas
we do this to try and understand what
are the different uh types of user bases
or customers that we have
um you can expect to create a lot of
um
scenarios that are essentially user
stories encapsulating how is it that
your user users are interacting with the
product what are their needs and how are
they using your products or services to
fulfill those certain needs and at the
same time what kind of need is going
unfulfilled because that is what will
represent a design need that your
organization can then help fulfill you
can also expect to be working with a lot
of storyboards that essentially draws
out and Visually represents
um what's the use of floor really looks
like what the
um
and then we go on
to build prototypes right so then we
take all of this assets these design
assets that we've created and we move to
the prototyping stage where
um we uh we first engage in paper
prototyping which we also call as low
Fidelity prototyping
um and there are often these uh levels
in prototyping where you don't directly
get on to doing building bioframes and
using tools such as stigma but you first
um
do them in a more uh in in an
environment that is much more low
resource because that is what is going
to help you catch errors catch mistakes
iterate try and understand
whether you're headed in the right
direction without investing too many
resources because the higher you you go
in the product
um development uh stage
um making mistakes becomes more
expensive and more costlier and
therefore first understanding your users
understanding what you're trying to
build at a low Fidelity prototype stage
allows you to catch
um a lot of these things and um it is at
that time that you also engage in user
testing to assess and understand uh user
behavior I'm actually giving you um what
the what a typical product uh design
cycle would look like this is not
necessarily something that will always
follow this range because when you are
working on existing products you're not
really building something from scratch
you have the benefits of a lot of user
metrics of a lot of data that is already
at your disposal and that dictates and
influences and shapes
um what kind of
um ux design activities you would like
to engage with
um you you can also expect to
um constantly be engaging in what we
call as competitive analysis because
you're not working in silos you're not
working in a vacuum
a lot of what you UI uh designers do
um is also in response to Market it is
in response to what your competitors are
building how is it that they are
approaching their Production Services
and therefore you cannot expect to
maintain a Competitive Edge if you don't
understand your competitors services and
products as well as you do your own and
therefore
um you we engage in competitive audit
analysis to understand how are our
products faring uh as compared to
um uh others in the market
um you could also expect to work a lot
on the visual features if if user
interface uh roles are what appeals to
you
um then a lot of visual design would
come in
um and what UI designers generally do is
that they'd be paying very close
attention into the visual look and feel
of your interface they would look at
things such as
typography color
um how and how can you leverage uh the
visual hierarchy of an interface how can
you understand information architecture
how do you understand information
perception memory recall
um to design interface uh input and
output elements so when we when we talk
about things like call to actions which
is what uh the word the acronym CTA that
you see on the screen stands for when
you're talking about layouts when you're
talking about what should you link and
what should these links lead to
um when you talk about you know how
should how should the look and feel of a
landing page be
um you are essentially referring to uh
the visual language the visual
philosophy
um that your particular product or
service
um will be greeting your customers with
um and then part of all of this really
coalitions under
um the banner of understanding product
specifications and user psychology so
the kind of activities that a typical UI
ux designer does would comprise all all
of these things right from identifying
who your target user groups are right up
to understanding what kind of
specifications does your product and
service need to develop because
um it's not that you conduct one user
research and and your job is done design
and research are iterative processes
which means they're cyclical and they
are never done if a constant Works in
progress we work on something we go to
the field we test it we collect data we
bring it back we develop something new
and so on and so forth this is this is
not something that ever ends and it is
it's the reason why whenever you open
your apps or whenever you look at gmail
or even if you've downloaded the recent
most recent version of WhatsApp which
was released a couple of a week or so
ago it now supports additional features
right it is it is now allowing you the
capability of doing
video calls with more than one person
um and the new version of WhatsApp also
has a lot of design changes that it has
rolled out
um so this is how design teams works and
this is how this is what you would
expect a typical UI or a ux designer to
do
so in this slide what you're seeing is a
sample job
essentially of a typical
um person who's engaged in roles uh that
uh that involve UI and ux specifications
so uh for instance this job description
says in this role you work with both
your design team and a development teams
to produce engaging intuitive enjoyable
user experiences for end users seems
designer you participate in product
Discovery design and delivery you work
closely with our clients to understand
the business needs and with end users to
understand their goals working with the
product owner you help develop a product
Vision you craft product Solutions and
present to the design team the
development team end users and
stakeholders to collect feedback and
iterate towards the best solution yeah
the word iteration again you establish
patterns and create familiar experiences
that reduce the end user's cognitive
load you directly impact the lives of
those on your team or client and most
definitely end users so the then what
what kind of requirements should you
have to be able to perform this role and
to be able to get hired here so the
requirements are that you need
experience using research and data to
guide recommendations which means that
you need to understand what kind of data
collection methods you should be using
to address different kinds of problems
um you need experience in prototyping
and presenting design Solutions so you
need to understand low Fidelity
prototyping High Fidelity prototyping
what is the difference between the two
when should you be using what
um you need to understand uh the
arguments the philosophies
um
around this term called as human
centered design which essentially means
that you place people at the center of
what you're trying to do because your
design has to support people in
executing certain actions you also need
familiarity with uh tools so these are
technical software such as stigma sketch
Adobe XD
um
the industry standard these days is
really uh Sigma but there are other
tools in fact you can even create
mockups and wireframes using nothing
more than even PowerPoint but Sigma
is the preferred is the industry asked
essentially because everybody is using
it the tool it's a it's a very
collaborative uh way to work so
therefore given that a lot of design
work involves working with teams uh
figma is is a preferred is the current
industry uh favorite
um familiarity with front-end
Technologies helps tremendously so if
you are able to do a little bit of
coding if you understand HTML CSS
JavaScript that is that works to your
advantage and um at the end of it all
one of the primary uh parameters that
you're charged on when you're applying
for any ux UI position
is really your portfolio right that
demonstrates
um how you have arrived at a user Center
design solution which really means how
have you thought of this particular
problem
um and therefore it is recommended that
when you're sending in your CDs when
you're sending in your resumes for a job
description of this kind
um even if it is not explicitly asked at
some point you will be asked to share a
portfolio that allows recruiters to see
um what kind of skills
um uh you possess and how are you able
to translate them into thinking about
problems and translating them into
Solutions
next slide
so the kind of career paths that are
available for people interested in the
domain of UI and ux you
uh see a lot of job roles listed here
um and different organizations uh hire
differently but to give you a sense a ux
designer would generally be responsible
for Designing the entire user experience
of of uh of the customers and the users
a ux researcher would be somebody who's
focused on uh going out into the field
speaking to users interacting with users
getting the data a UI designer would be
focused on
enhancing and designing uh visual
vocabulary
for the interfaces that they're building
a web designer or a web developer at a
front-end and a web developer would be
responsible for the more technical side
side of things where they are using HTML
they're using CSS
um so therefore you know just by
eyeballing this particular slide you can
see that uh UI uh jobs are pretty
interdisciplinary and
um it has scope for a lot of things
related to interface that may not
necessarily be very heavy on the
engineering requirements while still uh
being welcoming of people with technical
skills what would use to it thank you
okay and
I will start this first poll
excuse me for a moment as I
look around my camera
um
so this is now on your screen if you're
in Zoom if you are in one of our
streaming oops sorry
adjusted a bad thing here hold on a
second
I ended the poll before you can answer
it give me a moment and I'll fix that
for you
apologize
one of the bad things about having a
head cold it makes you
no worries things that are strange
okay
apologize for that let me launch this
one
which is a copy of the first one
and we'll just leave this open for
another uh 15 seconds but
is it because it's the reason you
haven't done this type of a program
until now that you haven't found
something that covers
all of the types of skills that uh Dr
Preeti mentioned is that because
you don't think you'd end up with a
portfolio the Practical experience is it
because you haven't found a program that
matches your learning style or is it
because you haven't found one that fits
your work schedules close the poll in
about five seconds
three
two
one
okay and I'm sure the results here
um the biggest concern for most of you
is the uh
ability to have practical experience
that you can share in a portfolio and
the second biggest is finding a
comprehensive curriculum
so
we will talk about
those aspects in this Advanced
certification program for UI ux design
and this is a five month program from
triple it Bangalore which is
completely delivered online on the
simply learned learning platform
it is a comprehensive curriculum which
we'll describe for you
um and it's aligned with the industry
requirements
Dr Preeti and her colleagues work with
um
companies that come to triple it
Bangalore asking
for help training their staff in
particular skills
particular job roles so this curriculum
is aligned to those requirements
includes integrated case studies
projects Labs that you do on the same
platform on which you take your online
virtual classes
so that you are a meeting regularly with
your instructors you know
virtual classroom format you interact
with your batchmates you interact with
your instructors answer their questions
and ask them questions
and it's all delivered online
all available to you 24x7 so other than
the fixed class times for the live
virtual classes you can do all the other
work on your own schedule whenever you
feel
that you have the time to do it but you
have 24x7 support
from simple learning triple it Bangalore
so that you are able to ask a question
or deal with a doubt or a blocker even
if you're working at three o'clock in
the morning on a project so
it's a five month program we say that it
takes perhaps 10 hours a week of
devoted time and at the end of the
process
you're going to receive a certificate
from triple it Bangalore that attests
that you have completed the program
successfully
and
that you have the skills that were
taught in the program so anyone asks
triple it Bangalore will vouch for that
along the way you'll have done a number
of Hands-On projects including a final
Capstone project which will give you a
portfolio that you can then share with
protect prospective future employers or
with your current employer uh you'll
have access to master classes including
master classes from people working in
industry
and uh from triple it Bangalore faculty
and simply learn also offers
job assistance
career service program for you to help
in finding your next job
that is something that extends after the
end of the program so for six months
after you earn your certificate
can you tell us about triple it
Bangalore for those who don't know
oh you're on mute I'm sorry
so I I was just saying shall I just wait
for the slide to come up it's still on
the poll question it's still on the poll
question yes okay hold on for just a
second let me
fix that
and talking about these things
all right are you seeing the the uh
slide for the
yes it's it's just come up uh now so
um triple lady sorry am I Audible
you are but uh
the second well Zoom wreath for me again
I apologize for that if there is a
issue with my configuration but nothing
it doesn't like when I uh
start the slide sharing so it goes
through this cycle
but I apologize for that
it the slide is back up now yes go right
ahead okay great so
um why triple it Bangalore for a course
like this so
um we were established in 1998 and we
have a very rich Legacy of engineering
education uh triple AIT bangalore's
mandate was to contribute to the I.T
World by focusing on education research
entrepreneurship and Innovation and
Engineering is not the only thing that
triple it Bangalore does now all of the
engineering Institute and that remains
our Flagship and lnc programs but um we
also have a very strong faculty presence
in areas related to it and society as I
mentioned in uh Digital Society it is an
interdisciplinary course that is open
for students from all disciplines and
um therefore to equip uh our students we
also offer courses in human computer
interaction of which uh ux especially
becomes a very important component of
the kinds of things that we teach so at
our Institute we have a lot of faculty
and student presence
um both geared towards interests in the
ux UI domain as well as the academic
research in the domain of human computer
interaction Science and Technology
studies Telecom regulation and policy
systems thinking
um and information technology and
development as well as economics our
Institute also Works in very close
partnership with the corporate sector
and while at the same time
um championing and upholding uh the
freedom of what an academic institution
should be standing for
straight
thank you for that and uh so the program
has
two potential paths for eligibility one
is to have a bachelor's degree with 15
or higher marks and this is also open to
people who are in their final year of
their bachelor's degree with 50 or
higher marks uh Homa
with 50 print marks you need to have an
addition one year of work experience
and in either case we're really looking
for people who are enthusiastic and want
to become either become UI and ux
designers or to increase their skills in
that field if they're already working
there so
with that I'm going to ask another poll
question hopefully Zoom will let me do
that
so
how much experience do you have
again work experience is only a
requirement if you don't have your
bachelor's degree in or only a diploma
holder at this point
I'll leave this open for another five
seconds
or three
two one and pull
so about half of our audience are people
who are currently studying
and the other half have experience
ranging
across the board
more skewed towards people knew in the
workplace but also quite a few people
who are more experienced
just want to share that to make sure you
get a chance to see it
and
let's talk about how this program
prepares you
and we'll start by talking about the
curriculum
and uh Dr pready if you want to jump in
at any point and uh
add to or correct anything I'm saying
but we start with uh
orientation session which is the first
step in this staircase of of skills
um we designed this curriculum so that
course gives you a foundation to to move
on to the next course and you can't move
on to the next course until you complete
the course you're on so
the orientation session induction
session as we call it is very
straightforward that gives you a
orientation toward the um learning
environment how to use the online tools
what class schedule to expect how to
access the courses
um what to do and where you'll find the
requirement to finish a course and get
your certificate for that course to move
on to the next one
all of that orientation uh happens in
the first session then you move on to
the first actual
course user experience design so
you'll be looking at
the basics and principles of how users
what user experience is and how
you would design a user experience that
is
satisfying and intuitive for your uh
users
then you move on from that into user
interface and design principles as Dr
pretty said it is uh
the visual vocabulary that your users
will encounter the the tools that you
use to build up the way the user
interface looks the principles of design
that guide your choice of those tools
and
the so so to speak the words in your
vocabulary
um
moving on from that you move into using
tools like figma for user interface
prototyping
and styling so that you can have
experience in how to build out
prototype of the UI that you're
designing
and
document it that will be part of the
Practical experience you'll be showing
off to people this is how I did this
process to take this Challenge and
prototype it out
then you'll move on to user experience
research and testing and gain the skills
and tools
Dr Preeti described for observing
customers end users
um
understanding business requirements and
then watching how users fulfill their
tasks related to your product
so that you can then feed that back into
the design process
and then finally a Capstone project
which ties together everything you've
learned in these modules into one final
challenge where you'll pick a uiux
design Challenge from several being
offered
you'll be able then to build your own
solution
and that again will be part of your
portfolio along the way you can take
the electives at your discretion you can
take as many or as few as you want but
we always recommend that you take as
many as you have the interest and time
for including master classes from triple
it Bangalore faculty
master classes from UI ux designers who
are working in industry
um you'll have a available module on
building websites from scratch and a
module on design thinking so all of
those are available to you at no
additional costs program
and you'll be working with a number of
different tools in the projects and Labs
that you do so when you saw in the
sample job description where they were
calling for experience with Sigma or
sketch you'll be using those tools in
the classes when you say using them that
means you'll have
projects that you must do in each course
and they will call on you to use the
tools to deliver the project
finish that course and move on to the
next one so at the end of the process
you won't just have these uh words to
put onto your resume as buzzwords you'll
actually be able to show examples of how
you've used each of them
that's a
very powerful part of the program sorry
going backwards
as I mentioned the Capstone project
Capstone project gives you the ability
to take a
real world oriented Challenge from
scratch and build your solution you'll
do it under the mentorship of an
instructor you'll meet with them weekly
make sure that you're not running into
any doubts or blockers that keep you
from completing your work
and then at the end of the process this
project will be evaluated and assessed
for your final certificate and it was
something that you take with you into
the future into your job search
I'm going to share with you
this brief video and the reason I'm
doing this is that it will show you some
of the uh
digital environment that you'll be
working on so
it happens to use an example from one of
our other university Partners digital
marketing
but you'll get an idea of how the actual
interface works
they need to succeed there are two
components that make our online boot
camp approach so successful great
content from the world's leading
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically designed for high
engagement and learner support when you
log into simply learn
the course timeline that meets your busy
working home schedule
we'll help you stay on plan with
automated and 24 7 human support
programs are our live virtual classrooms
where you interact with real time with
trainers that are recognized leaders in
their field there you will review
Concepts get questions answered and
interact with your peers important
reports on the audience if you notice
are demographics this is super useful
especially if you're my main acts but
it's happening you could do it on social
media later you'll learn social media
by looking at these numbers can be able
to understand the age range of people
that you should be targeting
you could just
only or
that's not all to learn from faculty at
Global universities and Industry experts
via master classes
ask your questions to the top industry
leaders in exclusive
interesting questions
and
optimize it okay so let's go back to
here right here where it says web
searches and you can see that there's
going to be the
okay
you can see that the YouTube searches is
going to be so there is a option uh
under not just web search and there's
going to be a
click on YouTube search and you should
be able to optimize it
towards you when we come across any sort
of original video
it can ask what appears between those
video content so be with this part when
we are watching an original video and
you need to do a video app and then go
back to the link
content
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice tackle practical
problems with multiple projects and
simulations and work on a real world
Capstone project that you can you could
showcase to Future
your learning isn't restricted to just
live classes explore our highly
effective self-learning videos and other
resources to fine-tune your learning and
remain up to
can focus on different learning
approaches by subject to personalize the
overall learning experience to your
learning style indeed
the end of it all
you need to walk away with globally
recognized certificates from top
universities for the program leading
companies for specialized courses and
simply learning so come on in experience
professional learning like you've never
done before get started today
all right and I I wanted to share that
because it showed you elements of the
learning environment how you manage your
curriculum how you take your live
virtual classes
um how you do projects and testing the
Capstone project
how you track your progress and unlock
other certificates for each course and
move on to the next one and the support
tools that are available to you so
talk about the
program advisors who designed this
course and the courses Dr Preeti and
there's
Professor street art and Professor
prakash who also
oversee the course again this is
designed by triple it Bangalore and
delivered by simpler so they chose us as
the delivery partner because of the
platform you just saw and they trust us
to deliver this content that they have
put together
um to teach you how to be an effective
UI ux designer so
I want to thank them for that trust in
us we also
um
include in the program the
master classes with working
ux designers so here are several of them
people from Amazon Microsoft and Adobe
who are working in the field who will go
through with you in those ask me
anything sessions that you talked about
you saw in the video and be able to
share with you what it's like to be a
working designer and what the the
day-to-day job requirements are and what
they work on so
talk about learner outcomes I want to
mention to you the
job assist service again this is
available within India
uh unfortunately we don't offer it
outside of India
but this extends for six months after
the end of your
um
program after you receive the
certificate Arnold did you want to
mention
talk about this or would you prefer I do
it
certainly so um
to uh holistically covered the four
major areas that um Jarvis's program
covers as part of this program with the
triple it boundaries particularly the
kind of support that we wish to extend
to all the Learners who are a part of
this program and this becomes effective
as soon as the learner is
joined or associated with the program
and can start availing the service as
soon as they are able to complete the
program in the given stipulative time
and with that they are provided access
to our hotel partner which is running
jobs for duration of approximately six
months and the key areas that we help
the learner focus and support them in
every way possible is to ensure the
resume building is top-notch and created
from a perspective that will help them
get noticed better in front of potential
employers
most importantly focus on Career
Mentoring sessions and discuss what
exactly would uh you know an ideal
interview session look like uh when it
comes to an opportunity uh for a UI or
ux designer and particularly turning
them through mock interviews in case
they are able to get opportunities
around uh the same role is uh what will
be covered as part of this job assist
program uh more details in particular uh
are available on the website I encourage
all of you to kindly visit the website
and check for the job assist program on
the page and most of the information uh
is mentioned as we saw as scrolled out
on the page itself for any further
details uh happy to connect uh with the
Learners with our team and discuss any
particular queries or in-person
questions that come up around this yeah
thank you and I always like to say that
the resume rewrite service and the
interview uh practice services are so
valuable because
things have changed over the years in
terms of how resumes are evaluated the
automated systems that process them and
being able to
tailor resume that both the automated
processes and the human interest
the human eye is really important as
well as being able to practice the
different styles of interviews that
you'll have to gauge in your job search
we also provide a series of webinars on
an ongoing basis that are available to
you so that you can
do things like uh
free life classes
on specific topics for an hour you can
do overviews of what's going on in the
industry or in the technology sector
what's currently going on and what seems
to be going on ahead the next months or
years
you can take classes on job search
skills and also on
developing soft skills for your career
so all of that is free it's ongoing
based on everything that um
Dr Preeti and Arnav and I have shared
with you today
are you interested
in
joining this program
and I'll leave this open for about 20
seconds
going
about 10 seconds more
and I will close in five or three
two
one
and about eighty percent of our audience
are interested in
joining this program so I'm going to
share with you how to do that
sure for share with you the poll results
you can see
and then
the enrollment steps are very
straightforward
um
you
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
and
we will send to you or put you in touch
with a learning consultant who will
verify your educational background
who will verify any work experience that
you want to claim and I'm putting the
the
email address into the chat right now
for you so you'll be able to find that
easily
then once I verified your